1995's Toy Story is arguably Pixar's
most beloved film for both kids and
adults kicking off a sprawling franchise
that's endured the test of time
rewatching Toy Story as a grownup
reveals the film as a dense sometimes
dark movie with more layers than one
could have ever imagined as a little kid
animators filled Toy Story with subtle
gags Easter eggs and cultural references
that very few children would understand
for example the character of mr. Potato
Head is voiced by the late great insult
comedian Don Rickles who was at the
height of his career in stand-up in the
60s and 70s at one point mr. Potato Head
makes a crack at one of Andy's other
toys you oxen swine referring to someone
as a hockey puck which definitely sounds
like something you can't say on TV was
Rickles signature line on the other end
of the spectrum is the super creepy
carpet and SIDS house
how can a carpet be creepy because it's
the same pattern as the carpet of the
nightmarish Overlook Hotel in the 1980
horror classic The Shining where we see
Danny playing with his toys come and
play with Woody and Buzz forever
something very intimate is definitely
going on between Woody and Bo Peep and
while kids might take their
conversations at face value adults in
the know recognize it as pretty
suggestive what do you say I get someone
else to watch the Sheep tonight oh yeah
what exactly they're going to do is up
for debates given traditional toy
Anatomy but there's no doubt about
what's going on here
Bo Peep is pre arranging a booty call
another risk a joke requires a bit more
unpacking one of SIDS freaky
Frankenstein's named legs and she
consists of what appears to be the long
shapely legs of a Barbie doll connected
with a hook on a line in other words
legs is a hooker Woody is a kind cowboy
in the vein of classic good guy
cowpoke's like Roy Rogers and Gene Autry
one thing that sets him apart is that
although he's the hero of the movie
woody makes a lot of attempts to get rid
of his new rival permanently woody moves
to get rid of perceived interloper Buzz
Lightyear intending to knock him behind
a piece of furniture so he'll get lost
he instead knocks him out of an open
window whether his little chance will
ever be found even worse he grabs a
remote
are see the remote-controlled car and
forces that toy to be the one to nudge
buzz thereby making RC an unwilling
accomplice usually in Disney movies it's
the bad guy who tries to kill the good
guy in Toy Story the good guy tries to
kill the other good guy Toy Story is a
movie for kids but some of its themes
are much more familiar to adults
particularly those who struggle with
mental illness at its core it's a movie
about anxiety delusions and the
disappointment of believing you're not
living up to your potential for the
first half of the film Buzz Lightyear
believes that he's not just a toy but
that he really is an actual Space Ranger
he has so firmly under that delusion
that he cannot see his reality for what
it is he hangs around self-aware toys
and lives in a child's room and even
freezes when real humans come around but
still does not waver in his stance the
only thing that makes buzz realize what
he truly is comes when he sees a TV
commercial for Buzz Lightyear toys and
in it sees rows and rows of himself on a
toy store shelf buzz immediately and
understandably becomes quite depressed
also dealing with an identity crisis is
woody the film's other main character
his main motivation for getting rid of
buzz is to remain the dominant toy in
Andy's hearts and toy box an
old-fashioned toy he's extremely
threatened by the shiny high-tech Buzz
Lightyear toy swooping in and stealing
his place as Andy's favorites
he's like a cowboy doll version of Willy
Loman from Death of a Salesman
desperately trying to hold on to
relevance and usefulness in a changing
world that finds him increasingly
obsolete the toys of Toy Story are
living things of course because they
clearly walk talk think and feel but
that isn't the same as being an actual
biological organism the main difference
between the toys and animals for example
is that they cannot die in a normal
fashion they're simply played with or
not played with if they are played with
great if not they sit on a shelf or in a
toy box or some other storage option
indefinitely aware of the passage of
time is they wait and wait and wait to
be played with a moment which may never
come we definitely know that toys can
die though since it blows up a combat
Carl action figure and Buzz nearly meets
his end in a similar way as Sid ties a
small rocket to his back even worse SIDS
homemade chimeras are also alive
Frankenstein together from other
dismembered toys so toys can die but the
only means by which to kill them is with
brutal pain
will torture and even that might not end
their suffering now that's dark check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff or coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Applause]